[Music]
kendall jenner brings out the vod the
tequila brand yeah 818 right and she's
totally fake
in the way that that she promotes it i i
put this tequila brand through all
60 different competitions for tequila
and all this other stuff and then people
do some research
and she's like i've been developing this
tequila for over three years people do a
little research and like apparently it
takes seven years to develop tequila
right apparently her tequila is made at
this factory that
60 other tequilas are made out of so
they just went
found a distributor put their name on it
and went out
the reason people are upset at her is
because she
put herself in a position to fail yeah
right
uh sorry that's not the reason they're
upset but she she lied
yeah and people couldn't wait to take
her down yeah
why could they not wait do they
is it because they don't believe that
her fame is justified no i think like
you said
it's because we hate the fraudulents if
she would have just said
hey guys they're paying me to put my
face on as tequila we would respect that
way more
son i really think it's a terrifying
proposition right you've put all this
money into a brand or maybe they haven't
put money but like you put all this time
or whatever
it's a terrifying proposition to be
honest it's absolutely terrifying for a
lot of people right
he's terrifying for me he's terrified
for most of us that's actually we
it's we'll get to it later but that's a
great segue into why patrice was amazing
yep honestly at all costs it costs to be
honest cost to be honest
but it provides in the end
i think in the immediate we'll talk
about patrice's honesty when we get
together
but let's just let's let's talk about
this yeah so it's like
cardi for example yep she was super
honest takes so much criticism and
pushback and
makes her life more difficult but her
rise to fame was like immediate
super fast i think um jay-z has
learned to shut up cardi is a perfect
example
because people were so happy for her
success
yeah as long as she was that honest
cardi
yeah come out with video [ __ ] i don't
care i chip my nail i'm not gonna pay
for a whole new [ __ ] set of nails i
just paid 200
for this [ __ ] i can't do that [ __ ] if
you broke my neck that like i walk
around with a broken ass nail and then
girls are like oh my god i love her she
walks around broken nails it's the
coolest thing whatever
and i think the when cardi started to
experience pushback is when she started
to do things
yeah when she started to get political
she started to get political even if she
does truly care about these issues
it seemed as if she was using her
persona
to push an agenda exactly instead of
just honestly
reacting to her environment yeah right
it
it wasn't like she was out there like
man
i don't really [ __ ] with bernie's tax
plan because i'm trying to save money
which she probably is trying to save
money yeah
it seemed like she was just riding the
wave of whatever that was
yeah and that's when i think that you
experience that pushback right it's like
when we know that there's a disconnect
there's some fraudulence there
why is it when people get to that level
they can't continue
to ride the honesty that got them there
or is honesty too costly at a certain
level it is costly
to those others at that level
advertisers don't want a lot advertising
is all
not honesty it's all dishonest
essentially i remember somebody brought
up the slogan back in the day choosy
moms choose jiff
jeff peanut butter sucks but that slogan
literally says
if you don't get jiff peanut butter
you're a bad mom
that's the [ __ ] slogan yeah all
advertising is is
we're trying to lie to you to get you to
get this product and if we're associated
with [ __ ] who are too honest
that's dangerous
look at a lo look at all the pushback
lebron got before like
when he didn't do anything with china
people are
coming at them because like hey what
you're mr socially conscious let's be
pro-black and now when these people are
suffering over there
you're for like you have nothing to say
you don't want to affect your pocket
and we've looked at that [ __ ] as
fraudulent it's fake like you're [ __ ]
for doing
it because he's just so big that any
little thing he says or
doesn't even say can hurt his because
he's so
um uh this is interesting he's so vocal
yeah but he is so vocal so we expected
that same level right when it came to
this other issue
that was similar in nature to the issues
he's so vocal about
right and it looked as if he chose his
pockets over
being vocal so here's a question do we
often conflate
honesty and being critical
of something that could hurt you for
being critical of it
say that again so like uh the the only
the example that i can think of right
now
and for whatever reason it worked out
but is like
i'm sure at least in the comedy
community the average person probably
couldn't give a [ __ ] but when i was like
yo netflix is done
at a time where everybody was trying to
get a netflix special
i'm sure there are people in the comic
community they're like yo he's truthful
he don't give a [ __ ] he'll say whatever
because
what i was saying was costly yeah okay
to me yeah so anytime you say something
that can cost
you money there's immediate truth
that's attached to it
from the from the perceiver anything you
do
and it clearly wasn't honest because
[ __ ] got a netflix special
but it was honest in the moment it was i
was wrong but it was what i honestly
felt in the moment
but um like for example when i just
froze over what the
[ __ ] but kanye for example when he was
like
george bush don't care about black
people yeah that's one of the greatest
moments
great moment media history even when he
went up and did the whole um
what's the blonde chick saying taylor
swift [ __ ] right it was like we trusted
that so much
because what he did could have cost him
we thought like yo
this doesn't benefit him in any way yeah
i trust this man
he keeps doing things because they are
the quote-unquote right things to do i
don't know if it's right to do that to
taylor swift or not
but like or if you write to say about
george bush or not it's a weird
indictment i don't know if you can prove
right
but there's an immediate trust
this point it's like the waiter telling
you one of the menu items is trash
yeah like you ever you ever asked the
waiter like right you're like
yo like is there anything what about the
lasagna and the waiter does that [ __ ]
like
yo i'll be honest with you like lasagna
is trying to garbage like i wouldn't
[ __ ] with
lasagna after the waiter says that to
you i'm like i'll trust this man with my
child
yeah i leave my dog when i go to cancun
i'm leaving my dog with the waiter that
told me the lasagnas
you don't care about yourself that much
so i can't wait to leave my dog this
weekend i'm gonna take a picture as i
drive away in the three series but
but but you know what i mean it's like
um i i feel like
oftentimes we could conflate those two
things
you know like there might be people that
are just saying
outlandish [ __ ] for attention purposes
not because they believe in it
like is what takashi 6 9 is doing right
now
a perfect example of that he's calling
out all these people and it's
wildly entertaining he's called yeah i
don't expect it because it's not
to your point it doesn't cost you
anything it earns you something this is
your
ticket to fame or money or whatever this
is an end for use
i'm just gonna draw all the eyeballs
negative or positive attention
to your point that's why i don't respect
the kardashians positive or negative it
all benefits them so whenever you do
[ __ ] for attention
or say something wild or do something
wild it's like that's what you do but
the initial
idea with takashi saying this initially
there was truth there we thought right
we're like oh [ __ ] this guy is willing
to call out all these other gangsters
some people start to believe like yo
this guy might be a super thug like it's
the real you calling out the crazy
you calling out the chicago
[ __ ] like joe
this guy's crazy he's he's really about
it he's really truthful
and then the second time around as he as
he's doing it
it still garners attention but you see
the fraudulence
because you're like oh he's just using
yeah i was using that did you see his
most recent thing he did wow boy
so so he has the little interaction with
me yeah
and then he takes the clip puts it in
the video in his music
yeah it's great it's a brilliant move
it's wildly corny i don't [ __ ] with him
but that was a yo yo you didn't see
what he did the the facetime live with
the chicago dudes yeah
that [ __ ] was crazy i know that [ __ ]
he's on facetime live with all the
chicago goons
like one after another and he's just
like yo don't talk tough
because everybody kills your people and
they don't end up getting killed oh
[ __ ] and he said rest in piss
oh my god he gonna get killed son he's
he's really asking to be killed
yeah i don't know why he's but is he
taking advantage of like this
natural like human reaction yes
and i guess that's what i'm trying
there's genius to that 100 jesus he's
like hacked the system
yeah right like and we'll get this is a
cool uh
segue into into patrice but like there
is the ability to like
garner attention in that way i just i
just
find that there is a distinction between
like following somebody and like rooting
for them and following someone and like
hoping for their downfall and i'm
curious if that's simply a function of
success
like you like to ride it on the way up
and the second it's up and things are
doing well for that person that you're
rooting for you're like man [ __ ] them
i'm not there and then or who are the
people that
because if you look at even little duval
there are people actively getting his
instagrams canceled every time it comes
back they can't there are people that
are [ __ ] hating on him
what is that what is the distinction
what is the turning point where's the
bell curve
i think certain people like different
things on that point for takashi for me
maybe i'm just old
but from the beginning i was like oh
this kid just wants attention he's
[ __ ] entertaining and he's wild
yeah and it's scary yeah and i'm
watching but i don't it's fraudulent to
me he just wants
awesome ultimate addiction to attention
yes yeah that's what i want to risk his
life like heroin [ __ ] are
willing to risk their life to get that
next shot
yeah he's literally willing to risk his
now i'm like legit
kind of starting to feel and this is the
oldest thing i'm ever saying but i feel
bad for the kid now
you're that addicted to this you need to
risk your life yeah yeah yeah
but there's actually a different i
remember when i was in college i asked a
couple of friends
would you rather be a good person but
everybody thinks you're not
or be a piece of [ __ ] and everybody
thinks you're a good person for me
i don't care everybody can think i'm a
piece of [ __ ] if i know i'm a good
person i'm good with that
the majority of people i asked was like
six or seven people they were like
oh i'd rather be the piece of [ __ ] that
everybody thinks is a good person there
is a different
wiring in people i think i think there's
two types ones that are okay with the
fraudulence and they like it i want you
to be i like what you present i'm good
with it
generally speaking and others are like
nah generally speaking i don't care if
you're fake
you're [ __ ] you if you're fake i want
honesty even if i don't like it
i think there are people are wired
differently i don't know what the
percentages are
but generally speaking i think those are
just two different wirings that people
have
man it's 100 true it's like dealing with
dealing with that feeling like i felt
that after the special
like it was the first time that i put
out
content that i was getting all this like
praise and accolades for
that i wasn't solely responsible for the
creation of the content yeah so i felt a
little bit of like
an imposter syndrome feeling i was like
i didn't do this alone right but i'm
being treated as if i did
because i'm the one who said it right
and i tried to be as vocal as possible
on the podcast and that stuff that this
was a
group project but like when i'm doing
stand-up and i think of a joke if it's
in the moment with somebody or if i'm
thinking of these bits like that's me
so i feel it's earned the adulation i
get from that yeah you know but like
if somebody was like yo schultz that was
absolutely genius what you said
like my gut reaction was like well you
know it was all of us we put this thing
together you know
because my body vomits yeah the idea of
um like an unearned
accolade you feel like a phony if you're
like a fraud you're like an imposter
impossible
i'm so happy that i'm getting this stuff
and everything but there's also part of
me that's like
it felt undeserved and
i don't know i don't even know why i'm i
don't know if this
is totally tied to what we're talking
about tied in with like that's your
wiring my wiring is similar yeah i walk
around thinking like oh i don't you know
this
imposter this i'm phony this and that's
maybe why almost certainly why i hate
fraudulents and other people
but i think there's just two types of
people and we tend to click because we
all prefer authenticity even if we don't
like it
and there's other people that are super
funny with each other and you're like yo
that's [ __ ] gross how are y'all even
friends
they might just be wired like that like
no i'm cool with the phony i want you to
be fine
like it's even on the podcast like you
even
like if somebody even says something
funny in our everyday
yeah we'll all reference that person
yes like that's how valuable
funny is to us yeah and authenticity i
don't want credit for something that's
not mine right
so if something funny is said
i have to say somebody's name that none
of the half million people that are
listening to this right now
know yes yeah fred said
and you're like who the [ __ ] is friend
yeah like i could easily i'm sure most
radio hosts
will just say the thing yep right but if
i say it and people like yo it's
hilarious what
like how often do some people the other
day someone tweeted like uh andrew said
uh florida yes what is it uh hong kong
is the
is the florida of china or something
like that and i was like nah i think it
was akash
oh wheels for president rolling the
president rolling for president i was
like nah
i had to correct twitter yeah and he
publicly did it which i appreciated
but the guys privately messaged me
yeah but i had to i had to correct
and i what maybe that is a function of
us knowing that in this business the
only thing that we
have is our ideas yes and when we get
credit for someone else's ideas we know
what it would feel like if someone else
got credit for hours
right so we feel like it's super
important that's our currency yes
we can't pay bills with that [ __ ] all we
have is ip all we have is our ip but we
can't do nothing with it it's worse than
bitcoin
yeah it's doge
you